North Korea claims it is successfully
tested an intercontinental ballistic
missile state media says the missile
reached an altitude of about 1,500 miles
kim jong hoon celebrated what would be
Pyongyang's first ICBM test the US
military calls an intermediate-range
missile president Trump reacted on
Twitter writing does this guy have
anything better to do with his life
perhaps China will put a heavy move on
North Korea and end this nonsense once
and for all the missile was launched
from a North Korean base near the
Chinese border it landed in the Sea of
Japan David Martin is at the Pentagon
David good morning good morning for now
the US military is sticking with its
assessment that this was an
intermediate-range missile not an
intercontinental ballistic missile but
intelligence analysts are still studying
the details and if this turns out to
have been an ICBM
this could likely become enforcement
prices kim giman has been saying since
it started this year that his country
was nearing the capability to test the
nuclear-tipped missile capable of
striking the united states however it's
still not known if North Korea has a
miniaturized nuclear warhead that would
fit on an ICBM North Korean state media
says this missile flew for about 40
minutes and reached an altitude of 1500
miles it splashed into the Sea of Japan
about 600 miles from the launch site
based on those numbers experts say it
could reach Alaska but not the
continental US or Hawaii if this was an
ICBM the next question becomes what will
the u.s. do about it the Pentagon has
already prepared options for shows of
force in South Korea including the test
firing of us missiles based there but
the options I'm told stopped short of
actually using military force against
North Korea Dana
David thank you North Korea tested that
missile just days before world leaders
gather for the g20 summit in Germany
president Trump will discuss the nuclear
threat with the leaders of Japan and
South Korea and the New York Times
reports the president warned China the
u.s. will act on its own to deal with
North Korea the White House said on
Sunday that the two leaders agreed the
Korean Peninsula should be nuclear-free
Ben Tracy is in Beijing with the issues
at stake this week Ben good morning good
morning so president Trump is once again
calling on China to help curb North
Korea's weapons program but for its part
China feels like it's done quite a bit
in terms of backing the sanctions on
North Korea now if you go back to April
when President Trump and President Xi
Jingping
met in Florida they seemed to form a
relationship and President Trump went
out of his way to compliment the Chinese
leader but that relationship seems to
have taken a negative turn Beijing is
upset that the u.s. sailed a Navy
destroyer near a Chinese claimed island
this past weekend and also issued
sanctions on a Chinese bank that it
accuses of aiding North Korea now
President Xi was in Moscow yesterday
where he met with
Russian President Vladimir Putin and
we're told they did discuss the North
Korean threat the Chinese foreign
ministry is urging all countries to show
restraint and it wants the u.s. to start
talking to North Korea to try to ease
tensions on the Korean Peninsula Rina
Ben Tracy and Beijing thank you Ben